[Musik]
da will man einmal mit den genossen
fette party feiern und dann vertraut uns
mal wieder der wähler das ergebnis
hätten wir auch mit gabriel haben können
hallo hallo ist das der richtige abend
für lustige verkleidungen nach zoom
kassenergebnis der muss jetzt
ausgetauscht werden martin schoser
torsten albig ich glaube gar keiner von
einer einer muss weg ist klar ein kopf
rollen logisch ich würde sagen das ist
angela merkel bei der nächsten
bundestagswahl die hoffentlich dann auf
dem scheiterhaufen der geschichte ende
als zweiter auch in der geschichte der
malerischen ufern rüberkommt heute ist
der tag einmal die fehler seien heute
mal gewinnen und ab sind sie mit dem
auto da schade
gerda und erich haben dann doch über den
tatort geguckt hat alleine auf die cdu
gewinner party und wer ist eigentlich
dafür egal hauptsache es gibt genug zu
trinken
ich kenne sehr schön wenn die einmal
jetzt erleben heute dieses super wetter
hier in kiel
wir haben hier nicht nur gute politiker
sondern auch viele betrunkene frauen
wissen was man auch heute feiert kinder
spd user verein oder ist doch so
na ja sagen ja ja ja
risiko ist ein wunderbares land und
nicht einfach nur hinter schließlich
wissen noch nicht genau wo es liegt aber
hallo
das gehört jetzt alles so weit das auge
reicht so weit der adler fliegen kann
ich meine abwiegen sehen großartiges
ergebnis
glückwunsch aber es war ja schon risiko
so ganz ohne spitzenkandidat ins rennen
zu gehen
er ist ja noch geworden in der letzten
zeit hatten einen spitzenkandidat daniel
tünte hat sich doch in den letzten tagen
noch wenn sie gar nicht wieder aus
daniel günther biwer er bewegte nach der
nachbar günter der nachname von daniel
günther
die brille oder was die brille und jahre
junger mann ganz junger mann brille oder
keine brille eine brille eine brille
und dann kommt jemand der daniel günther
frappierend ähnlich wie ohne brille mit
brille
ach egal sprechen einfach mal an herr
günther herzlichen glückwunsch zu fünf
jahren in denen sich deutschland nicht
mehr für sie interessieren wird
es war ein harter wahlkampf wie auch mal
ruhe überhaupt keine ruhe sondern jetzt
geht erbrecht los wenn wir gewarnt
anpacken statt rum schnacken von drei
nicht gewählt worden um mich auszuruhen
sondern um was für schöne schleswig
holstein zu tun und dann werden auch wir
wissen wer ich bin
alles klar dankeschön das war jetzt war
das jetzt erreichte heute ein wichtiger
tag ein großer park makro hat gewonnen
ist sonst was passiert heute in
deutschland wird eine neue
bundesregierung dann ein wichtiges auch
heute noch was wichtiges passiert das
wichtige und damals durch michael lang
[Applaus]